foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
huh
hi uh hello I'm I'm a human being from
the top world
you probably don't understand a word I'm
saying do you of course I understand you
what do you think I am one of those
mindless monsters that's right bub
you're in the presence of the one the
only Yeager dad
follow me
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
stop embarrassing me out here
that's awesome he is not awesome he just
saved my life you know I was a part of
that rescue too he just saved your life
I ain't seen nothing yet kid
[Music]
wow it's beautiful oh I wish everyone in
avalonia could see this oh what is that
whatever it is it knows your name
what Meridian what are you doing down
here we've been trying to flag you down
for the last four hours our sun is on
your ship what did she just say honey
what do you saying what is she saying
she said your son is on our ship hey Mom
Ethan oh hey Dad you brought the dog
what what are you doing here look Dad I
just want to help Ethan we talked about
this I can't I need you to take care of
the farm while I'm gone now please go
home with Mom wait but death
[ __ ]
[Applause]
what is happening dad what are those
things what are you doing trying
to try it outside if you think you can
reach your arm under here and up to the
door handle clearly no wait what's that
noise
hey boy hey open the door yeah
that's Mama's baby you can do it can you
not yell at my dog yell if you were
actually trained he is trained he hasn't
been in the house for the last two days
I've been on this ship for the last two
days
[Music]
[ __ ] it there's a switch right beside
the handle Legend you see the switch
what is that sound is he licking the
switch Legend stop licking the switch
[Music]
what kind of Airship is that I've never
seen anything like it baby clayed what
is the president doing in our front yard
our entire world is in grave danger I
want you to come with me on an
expedition
I'm not my father he was the Explorer I
know you were just a kid when you went
missing but now
you're all we got
I'm a huge fan thank you [ __ ] your dad
do you think think you could Forge his
autograph
where in the
window are we
sorry
[Music]
we are clearly in Uncharted Territory
[Music]
[Applause]
hello you probably don't understand a
word I'm saying of course I understand
you
dad dad Grandpa I'm a grandpa what is
this place the cliffs are alive and the
waters dissolve the flesh off your bones
everything down here is trying to kill
us
[Music]
foreign
do you mind if I call you splat you just
kind of give me Splat Vibes
I guess I deserve that
Grandpa's awesome he is not awesome you
gave me a machete for my birthday
classic Jager claimed I was too
I'm loving this family reunion oh come
on we got a world to save
[Music]
I need you to figure this out otherwise
we're doomed we are doomed wait
seriously no I'm just messing with you
didn't see that coming
[Music]
strange world is crazy bizarre
adventurous mysterious exciting
thrilling dangerous mind-blowing so many
other vocabulary words but most of all
strange strange strange strange it's a
strange World our mission is dangerous
if you want to back out this is the time
you do it
we're the place we love danger
they Venture into this very strange
world there's danger around every curve
the cliffs are alive and the water will
dissolve the flesh off your bones the
flamethrower comes in pretty handy
Grandpa's awesome he is not awesome
there's a lot of history between the
Searcher and his father how are you my
dad when two people love each other stop
talking stop talking
wall of monsters
that's what I'm talking about okay here
did you miss me
do you mind if I call you swag so cute I
want to merchandise it it's three
generations learning to be okay with
everyone charting their own course I
love that I'm loving this family reunion
but come on we got a world to save
strange world is beyond your wildest
imagination
a good time you'll love strange world
stop pushing buttons bad splash
mm-hmm
foreign
[Music]
common uh they're cute well yes but they
are all iconic lovable Disney characters
in celebration of Disney's 100 Years of
Wonder it's our honor to introduce you
to the newest pair of characters
meet Splat will you get that off your
head
and Legend now not everyone can be an
iconic Disney character
that's right they must exhibit these
very important traits Intelligence
being quick on your feet
I'll just follow you sass
humor
I know I'm happy too if they're loyal
Brave
then they've always got your back
hey boy
thanks buddy journey into the strange
with splatin Legend in Disney's Strange
World only in theaters November 23rd
[Music]
foreign
[Music]